Je ne vous veux aucun mal,
je ramasse juste la saleté.
Vous courez tout pile
où il y a des miettes, c'est pour ça.
Il est chaud, cet épisode.
Putain, je viens de recevoir
un mail pour les aspirateurs.
Ah, ouais !
Connexion, quoi.
C'est tellement Black Mirror.
Comment ça ? De quoi ?
Oui, enfin, c'est peut-être une coïncidence ou…
Enfin, je crois que je ne capte pas
ta définition de Black Mirror.
Il faut que tu…
Genre, par exemple, ça,
c'est quoi, par exemple ?
C'est Black Mirror, ça.
C'est un téléphone.
L'ordi sur lequel on vient de regarder
l'épisode de Black Mirror.
C'est Black Mirror, aussi.
Genre, ça ?
Ça, c'est Black Mirror, ça.
Attends, fais voir, vas-y.
Ouais, Black Mirror, ouais.
Il doit vraiment vous manquer.
Pas de souci,
ne vous inquiétez pas, je ne juge pas.
Moi aussi, j'hésitais
à utiliser cette application.
Une application, quoi ?
Quelle application ?
Bah, vous avez bien utilisé l'application
qui permet de cloner les êtres chers décédés ?
Ben, ouais, c'est ça.
En fait, tout ce qui est
un peu électronique, futuriste,
pour toi, c'est Black Mirror.
Mais, par exemple ça, ce truc immonde ?
C'est Black Mirror, ça.
Je ne comprends pas.
Oui, docteur.
Écoutez, c'est assez urgent, là.
Elle sort tout juste de la réalité virtuelle,
mais j'ai l'impression qu'elle s'y croit encore.
Oh là là.
D'après ce que j'entends,
elle est enfermée dans un corps
d'une jeune femme de 20 ans.
Oh, laissez-moi pécho des meufs !
Je veux de la chatte !
Oui.
Oui, oui, c'est Claudette.
- Oui, par contre…
- C'est bien fait.
Non, ne touche pas, s'il te plaît, par contre.
- C'est le mien, tu vois.
- OK.
- Attention à ta tête.
- Mais c'est cool, en tout cas.
- C'est super réussi.
- Ouais.
Je crois que je vais le faire,
parce que quand je le vois comme ça, je me dis…
- Ça ?
- Black Mirror.
Black Mirror.
Je vous présente le clou du spectacle.
Figurez-vous que dans
ce petit ourson a été enfermée
la conscience d'une personne
assoiffée de sang et de combat.
Comment ça ?
Je vais vous montrer.
Armand !
Mais c'est Booba !
Maman.
Boo quoi ?
Vous ne prenez pas votre…
C'est bien fait hein !
Je vais le garder, en attendant.
Si je te dis :
"Est-ce que tu m'entends hey ho ?"
"M'entends-tu ?"
C'est Black Mirror, ça.
C'est pour cela qu'avant 18 heures,
sur toutes les chaînes de télévision en direct,
le Premier ministre doit copuler avec un porc.
Sinon, ils vont me tuer.
Messieurs, il va falloir trouver
une solution très rapidement.
Mes équipes tentent de localiser
l'endroit de la transmission.
Dans quelques heures,
ça va être compliqué.
Sinon, vous ne vous prenez pas la tête.
Je le baise, le cochon, moi.
On a tous les rappeurs disponibles en peluche.
Vous avez…
Méga pute.
Je vais t'enculer.
(Pa-ra-ra).
Eh !
J'adore le rap.
Pardon ?
J'ai dit : "je le baise, le cochon".
Monsieur, on va tout d'abord continuer
à chercher une solution alternative.
J'ai dit ça pour aider.
Oui.
Il y a quand même une vie en jeu.
Vous comprenez.
Nous saluons votre volonté de soutien,
Monsieur le Premier Ministre.
Vous êtes formidable.
On vous tient au courant.
Suivez-moi, je vous en prie.
Madame la Conseillère,
est-ce que par hasard
vous avez une photo du cochon ?
Ouh là !
Bonjour, je suis Olivier de Carglass.
Je croyais que tout était vrai,
mais, depuis le début, tout était
dans mes lunettes de réalité virtuelle.
Quel twist !
Tous les sketches, depuis la première vanne.
Moi, je ne m'y attendais pas.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais…
Ce n'est pas ouf comme twist,
mais quand même, moi, je trouve ça ouf.
On trouve ce qu'on veut de ouf ou pas.
C'est subjectif, les gars.
Bonne fin de vidéo.